tell us a story about buds so-so buds is
the basic SEAL training that you see on
TV and that you see carrying people
carrying logs on their heads and boats
around and do them push-ups and pull-ups
and getting wet and Sandy and the reason
that I don't talk about buds a lot is
because it's not it's a tiny tiny
fraction of what the SEAL Teams is all
about hmm and in fact when you get in
the SEAL Teams you realize that buds is
nothing more than a screening process to
weed out people that don't really want
to be there but if you compare it to
what you have to do once you get in the
teams it's actually nothing because
there's no way that you can compare hey
you got to go get in cold ocean water
and then roll around in the sand Oh No
and and I always think back to the first
time when I was in new I was in at Camp
Corregidor and I'm rolling out on the
first major operation we were doing in
the Milaap district of her body and
there's tires burn in the street there's
smoke you can hear the gunfire it
getting wet and Sandy and being cold is
a joke compared to that hmm so that's
why the the whole buds thing is is
something that I just it's not that big
of a deal and I think I think some guys
try and turn it into a big deal
especially if that was kind of a
highlight of their career was going
through SEAL training yeah but if you
were in the teams and you deployed
overseas then that shouldn't be the
highlight of your career shouldn't be
the highlight of your knowledge
shouldn't be the highlight of your of
your that the man test that people like
to consider Bud's not a man test means
you didn't quit being cold
good job it's and to that point I think
it's you know for those folks that
didn't really get tested in combat or
didn't get a chance to go out on the
battlefield and experience the gist
incredible physical nature of combat and
how difficult it is then you know buds
is like everything so they talk about
buds all the time and so it's kind of
this legendary thing it look it's a
great training program it's been around
for a long time it it screens out the
people that don't have the
characteristics as Jocko said that we
think are gonna be successful and it
works and we should keep those standards
high and we should push that I thought
butts was a pretty good time we had some
great times and BOTS
I love the guys I went to bullets with
most of them and but it's it's got
nothing on combat and you know it's
interesting that some of the the big
political discussions today you know one
of them one of them is the integration
of women into the SEAL Teams into
special operations into infantry units
and everyone's always focused on you
know well if they can meet standards and
and if they're you know if if they can
make it to the training and they should
be they should be you know they should
be able to go out and serve right and
they're focused on training and the
people they're talking about training at
the highest levels cuz they don't know
what it's like to be in a real combat
and real combat is infinitely harder
than the toughest I mean why are we
talking about integrating the NFL well
you got huge big strong guys that are
smashing each other and yet that's you
know maybe you get a concussion maybe
you tear your ACL maybe you break your
your elbow you know or snap up a snap
your wrist you're not gonna get killed
very rarely does someone get killed in
the football game right and word combat
is is infinitely harder than that in
fluent in that and and so you know and
unlike a football game that's over and
you know just a couple of hours you're
talking about something that can last
weeks months even years and and it's
just the physical nature of combat
cannot be overstated it is incredibly
difficult and when people are shocked to
hear that I'm not gonna tell me some
stories about bugs carry some logs man
don't don't quit okay I mean it's it's
make it through you know yeah its combat
well you're you're and you'll see it two
guys who excelled in buds because
they're great athletes sometimes I'll go
to the battlefield and like I remember
the first time that an AED I saw an AED
going off about a block away from me
and we were sitting on the rooftop and a
sniper positions my first appointment
before jock and I were working together
and all of a sudden there's a hundred
fireball that goes up in the air I mean
the blast wave hits me and just knocks
me on my ass
and frag just metal fragments and shards
of concrete and stuff is just raining
down all over the place from from a
block away you know from us and it was
it was a damn that is that is not
something I want to be standing on
around in a vehicle only hit that thing
and and when you see something like that
like just the the kinetic energy of a
rounds coming in and just you know think
of the biggest strongest guy you can
imagine with a sledgehammer you're
smashing a wall next to you and you know
multiply that times seven or eight
hundred rounds a minute for a belt-fed
machine gun and I mean it's incredibly
difficult and dangerous and overwhelming
and so you see some of the toughest guys
I did well buds are like ooh
not necessarily eager to go out in that
and so it's a whole new level of
difficulty and and it's it just it can't
be overstated so I think that it's it's
the difficulties of combat again kit
just cannot be overstated people need to
understand what the reality that is like
I think this idea that America is not
gonna oh we kind of dictate the nature
of wars and you know as we've been told
the tide of war is receding and it's
just not true as Jacko's said in his
retirement speech the nature of war does
not change and we're gonna always have
to fight horse we're gonna always have
to be a difficult conflicts we don't get
to choose that and so we better be ready
for those those difficulties in the late
90s we would hear that from from senior
leadership that you know look the the
direct action mission we're not really
doing these those anymore why would we
do direct action mission when we can
send an ax Tomahawk missile and then oh
why would we do a reconnaissance when we
can send over a drone and why would we
go clear buildings house-to-house when
we have technology that can put bombs
right into buildings so this idea that
we're gonna have the ground wars are
over we need to move on to the next
phase of warfare and and adapt to a new
way of doing things and of course what
was it eight years later sometime
xi happened we spent 15 years in
Afghanistan and whatever ten years in
Iraq that on the ground doing those very
missions that everyone thought we would
never do again so so yes the nature of
war does not change and it's not about
technology either you know some of the
guys that don't make it to that training
think oh man if I just if I could just
get through somehow and I'll get all
this cool gear and I'll have
night-vision and lasers and I'll be
badass it's like it's not about that and
and while we need to when you invest in
technology certainly and equip our
military accordingly it's the people
that matter
it's leadership at all levels that
matter you know one of the one of my
favorite quotes from the hero the
Pacific War who was in charge of the
entire it was the commander-in-chief of
all forces US forces the Pacific I got
em Chester Nimitz Fleet Admiral Chester
Nimitz good ol boy from from Central
Texas and he said our armament must be
adequate to the needs but our faith is
not primarily in these machines of
defense but in ourselves and I mean
that's that's just exactly true and we
kind of we've got to always push those
standards keep those standards I prepare
people for the difficulties of real
actual combat and just how physically
demanding it is and crushing it can be
and and be ready so then we can execute
and we can win next next back to Budds
real quick that's how long is Budd six
months right
yeah but 27 weeks or so because a lot of
money said it's like you know hell week
right that's the time where do you don't
sleep that much or whatever I think some
people think that that's but you know
like you just don't sleep ever and it's
all hard they drowned you and then they
bring you back yeah